some lessons are better lived than
learned pain is the greatest motivator
correct and experience is the greatest
teacher the hardest thing is can you
come out here from nothing
and be greater
than what you was before
legitimately like legitimately can you
legitimately be the greatest version of
yourself and it's so easy to revert back
to Old Habits I just like to be around
peace
and if you've went through and
experienced as much pain as I have I've
been through a tremendous amounts of
pain
physically mentally spiritually I've
been through hell in order to appreciate
and understand great peace
you have to have went through and
experience great pain and if my heart
not telling me do it I'm not gonna do it
I believe that the key to happiness is
self-accountability every day that I
woke up with breath in my body was the
opportunity
to change my life
because it starts inside it doesn't
start outside energy is my first
language
it's gonna always be the end the times
that I did not here to what my heart
chakra my inside so to say was telling
me
people say your gut feeling the times
that I didn't adhere to those type of
things I always suffered the
consequences
and through that suffering that was a
lesson and the lesson learned was I
needed to pay more attention to me pay
more attention to the energy I'm on the
journey now learning to love a stranger
that was once myself because everything
I did was detrimental to me so I hated
myself I didn't love myself even the
people I allowed myself to be around you
ever had a conversation with somebody
that need you strained all the life out
of you you wasn't protecting your energy
protecting your energy is not a crime if
I don't like you I'ma stay away from you
I put positive energy into my body
because the world beat us up all day we
got to give us our ourselves some
positive reinforcement like heartbreak
is very very real and like if you a man
I'm really most speaking of me ain't
nothing wrong with crying that is how we
heal that is how we release when people
start loving themselves the world
changes because I see me and you you see
yourself in me we see ourselves in each
other because we love ourselves we're
not just loving the people in our
household right so that's what make it
beautiful I want to see what can I gain
from this situation as opposed to
blend my ego lead like I I just had to
learn how to kill my ego because I don't
never want my ego to go before me I want
to operate out of love
life is a context but
and I use that I associate that same
willpower with what I do now my hustle
it's Relentless I'm not gonna stop I
took a lot of losses to get where I'm at
you know what I'm saying I took a lot of
losses I watched the movie and he said
why do we fall Bruce
so we can learn to pick ourselves back
up I respect the heart I respect the
Integrity I respect the morals and the
principles of an individual
what is success
what is your measure of success my
measure of success is me being able to
do whatever I want to whenever I want to
Freedom is not you being free freedom is
you being free in your mind and your
heart and your spirit which is really a
privilege for you to be free being your
authentic self is beautiful right and
that's the greatest Freedom that I
learned and I learned that comparison
was the killer of all joy because I'm
comparing my life to other people's High
Life films or the elixir of life it does
start with meditation you ever went to
sleep and woke up tired the mind
was never quieted the mind never
received true risk and I ain't trying to
sound like no philosopher no profit or
nothing but
I'm not happy but I am at peace right
now I'm to my pure Peace A lot of people
can't be alone with themselves
they can't right I can be alone with
myself I don't need to talk to nobody
and nothing I can talk to myself and
figure it out a lot of people don't want
to face themselves right and that's an
Act of Valor that's commendable because
through isolation is where we reach
elevation that's when most of my opinion
is happening when I'm alone so I commend
you on that like that's beautiful that's
where my ideas come in my solitude when
I'm working up yeah oh yeah and I talk
to myself out loud yeah I know if people
be like I used to be like man I know I'm
weird but then I read that all Geniuses
talk to themselves like I asked myself
questions I talk to myself yeah when we
get outside of our spiritual
belief system and we adopt the ways of
others we suffer the same demise as
those people that we adopt their ways
whoever they are I think being a skeptic
is a beautiful thing because being a
skeptic makes you investigate it makes
you ask why and when you ask why that's
how you get the truth you have to ask
why so being a skeptic is not a bad
thing you know like I say the knowledge
is powerful great knowledge in the hands
of a fool would be self-destruction and
I just I'm not about to give all that
away with great wisdom comes great grief
the wisdom was worth more than gold and
fine silver but because by wisdom all
things could be obtained I don't know
about anyone else but the worst thing a
man could be is a call to his own self
and I'm just big on respect that's why I
give so much respect and I don't place
myself in environments where it could be
challenged I love you but I love me more
I'm on my Mission I know my mission
though and I fell in love with that
mission when a man meets his mission he
and his mission become one I've just
found a way to deal with depression in a
way that makes me happy right as far as
finding my gratitude when you always
living to please others you're gonna
always be in a constant state of
depression because you never doing
nothing for you when you start doing
things for you to make you happy
then you can make somebody else happy
because you're happy I believe that you
either learn faster you die young you
know in a room full of clowns man I
can't be part of the circus man would
you entertain a clone you become part of
the circle
it's not a it's not a race right it's
not a destination it's a journey it's
your life it's about feeling good I
always knew who I was I always knew what
I was and if I did anything I took full
responsibility for what I did no matter
what they're good or bad I took the full
responsibility for it and I understand
that this is what I signed up for I
enlisted for this I always knew what I
was and who I was
and I know
what my job is and I always ran from it
I am now fulfilling my purpose now this
the things that you don't want to do
that'd be the best things for you the
days I don't want to go to the gym
that's the days I have my best workout
I wish they had a magic button if you
don't work you don't eat if you don't
grind you don't shine Roger Kipling said
to thine own self be true
and that is the greatest reality so if
you skateboarder you ride BMX bikes or
dirt bikes or whatever you into that is
the real you if you're not afraid to be
who you are that is the real you you are
only a victim of the energy that you
project
I prepared night to have a great morning
I don't just get up and Freestyle right
like at night time I already know what
I'm probably gonna wear in the morning
some workout clothes I'm gonna take me a
cold shower I'm gonna drink me some hot
water key lines I'm gonna pray do my
stretches
I go to the gym I do my core I do my
cardio
full bite of everything
and they just make my ages beautiful
whatever your process is sometimes I
listen to the nature sounds or the rain
that's recovery also for the body
I do that and in the morning I'd never
get on my phone I go straight and get
the hard part and I do my workout first
my therapy I do things that's going to
give me energy I can get that done first
right then I start my day